you were so bad it sometimes you  describe you get hit by a chicken wing  like someone would actually fling Nancy  yeah they've exceeded have performed on  a male strip club night in between in  between setups no good I'm a bunch is  that the worst gig ever a bunch of  people were there first of all to got a  guy through the wind got me I was like  why are you even here  that's all taking my mind he's like hey  man enough yeah you just do a saucy  buffalo wing at me hit me in the side of  the face but here that's like why why  are you even at this [ __ ] place  this guy was willing to take his food  and throw it on the head like he was so  frustrated with my joke that he'd been a  piece of and said that is enough what is  it about you that kept you going after  something like that I just I don't like  to lose man I'm not I'm not a guy to  taste losing whoa  you could see Kevin Hart and ride along  too